and then take it with him into the game here we
go we're underway and it's blasic that'll get the
pop first he'll ring it into the Canadian Zone
Ken gie after it Perry out of the way kby send
it around for C Coffield holds on Suzuki switches
spots the captain down to Coffield Hill weit has
to chase it back to the point gave it to Mattis
from Drive the goes wide say Rie the Caufield
on the boards back to mat mat moves to the middle
bloats it towards could get a stick on it mat the
got it again Canadians buzzing shot stop by mazic
and it's fired out off the boards by Rees Johnson
and he'll get it down the ice Josh Anderson trying
to get around Jor B bodies Collide back to the net
there J Murphy and boled as well new hook up High
Jack ey waiting with a shot and it's blocked by
Tyler Johnson Jacky feeds it across for y sovi
in the middle Gallagher's got it shoots blocked
rebound and that's blocked as well by Tori gager
on the puck again jack gu calling for it here's
hook waiting waiting sh Anderson knocked it wide
power play comes to an end Blackhawks will clear
it down the ice this will be an icing call oh it's
waved off on had to come out to play [Applause] it
binski got it into the quarter Dickinson tried
to center it good thing for the Blackhawks it
was waved off as they were able to get the change
in and collect themselves as the Canadians had the
pressure going here's El stopped byzic a power
play that was going for the Canadians Frozen and
fr picked off by Jake Evans and away he goes
short-handed Jake Evans trying to get around
he comes up with a big save off Harvey shorthanded
radish for Conor Berard the other way Berard
trying to go back to radish it's broken up Pinsky
on it he'll Circle away from Jordan Harris feeds
it over for Nado hands it back Kinski to Bard
Conor Bard wait shoots into the club but mono
and he holds [Applause] on it's everything
around him and that's the media that's the
fans that's everything he adapts it in he finds
a place for it but he keeps his focus on the at
hand and he's enjoying every minute of it I'm sure
he's had convers patience with Sydney Crosby Conor
McDavid and the likes of those guys who've already
gone through [Applause] it here's glassic takes it
around the net centered in front for Dickson
hopped away Cory Perry on the puck Perry off
for Felino back to Perry hangs on to it Perry
tried to get it towards a goal that'll float
off to the corner blassic off for kovich Cory
Perry on his back around the net Anderson played
it up for cof Dickson gets to the way Anderson
on the puck waits to stay outside plays it for
Coffield if move the Coffield in the opening
goal in Montreal what the doctor ordered for
the Canadians you're in your home building it's
your home opener let's get the first one Anderson
does a nice job of cutting across the Blue Line
holding on to it till Coffield can get into place
slides it over to what a nice move on the rookie
kinsky although he doesn't get in across he gets
to the inside of his backhand gets it upstairs
and it finds its way down and mat will lead it
out for the Canadians flips it on for sovi ands
coming to the net for mat and mazic made the
save Tori try to make that pass went right
into the feet of Mahan he'll take it away
Monahan the gager stopped by as it Tanner
Pearson hands it off for Monahan he gets
it back Pearson centering in front that's off
a stick good stick by Kaden gouie knocks the
puck away from Boris K now it is Monahan and
he'll get it around the board it's Pearson
up ahead through Center gie will lead the rush
rolled it over to Tanner Pearson and a shot by
Tanner Pearson line had some great years here
in Montreal and was a real sniper and you look
at Pearson he's kind of the same elk you know
he's not the most dynamic skater but he finds a
way to get in the right place at the right time
and he's got a really good release and a really
good shot and he pulls a trigger on this top of
the circle and that was in now r k it by hary
perard Rafael hary perard shorthanded stopped
byz zard following up with the play MZ get to
reach out with a stick now it's Bard he'll feat
it up for cor Perry Perry after the puck in the
corner drops it off for Bard rolled to the point
rinsky has got it rinsky will'll Skate It Down
Low up high Conor vard takes the shot and it's
blocked by SAR Bard's got it back Conor vard
looks to the net gives it out to Seth Jones Jones
for vard he'll shoot and he stepped it high over
the net it's off the glass to the line and out
Harvey perard for Shan m short him it's [Music]
go here penard gets to it he chips it into
the middle and there's just nobody there
other than Shawn Monahan Bard's trying to
get back but he's not going to get there
in time this really good penalty killing
by the Montreal Canadians tonight and they
get but like any player of the ilk of Conor
Bernard he will figure it out and when he
does look out still some four on four time left
here to start the third period with Cory Perry
and aror Jacky in the box binsky across for Tyler
Johnson stopped at the line Taylor radish Waits
gave it back for Seth Jones don't think he
was expecting that pass right to sha the puck
bumped by Nick Suzuki Johnson for Kinski under
his stick Jones follows up Coffield got in his
way now Johnson drops it off for Jones throws
it towards n shots cor the [Applause] scores
Tyler Johnson gets a bounce on his stick in
front and he gets the Blackhawks on the board
35 seconds into the third to Seth Jones who
follows up to play tightly and I thought he
was going to one time it there and instead he
fires it it hits the right skate of gouie and
when it hits the right skate it kind of it's a
fortuitous Bounce That kind of follows Johnson
and he's got himself a 3-1 lead with 1246 to go
pick Suzuki up with the puck throws it around
the board T Jacky fires Big Block in a plink Ares
Johnson Johnson cutting to the net the hand goes
wide Jacky's drive there was 99.8 milph a lot
behind that one now here's Gutman with a Chance
kuk knocks it down fed the point for Murphy
off the Gutman Oris kachuk throws it towards
the steered away off the outside of the r moris
kuk trying to make him play with it broken up
by Anderson Harris js on a cutfield going to
miss Carris W shoots is it with a stop Alex
BL it up it takes the hit from Evans back to the
py with a shot stop mizing he FS it away out of
the air plays it up Jones back for Conor Bernard
Berard got it down to Johnson back for Bernard
he'll wait try to feather it through scramble
in front scores Tyler Johnson his second on
the night and with 121 to go the Blackhawks are
within one one and Cory Perry who we know takes
up a lot of oxygen in front of the net he's
standing right in front of monbo and with six
attackers on the ice both defenseman really
can't just lock into because you got guys on
both sides you got Donado on the left you got
Johnson on the right Jones for Conor Bernard
Bernard way Johnson P for Bernard over to ath se
Jones shoots off the co they going for Bernard
back to Jones Anon the seal firon the SE for
Jones shooting the canans hold on and Win It